bon bah je vais y aller pas à temps il
faut qu'on fasse une photo d'abord je
suis bateaux et des pontons dans la
semaine j'ai plus de place bah on a fait
la prochaine fois parce que la fremm
depuis 13 ans ok bonjour papa ouais bah
là il est en séminaire pendant deux
semaines je t'ai pas dit trop bien
là-bas courage qui n'appelle pas la
place par l'état catastrophe les gars on
a un problème
je crois que damien il veut supprimer
l'un d'entre eux doutent fritter reste
trop qu'il va supprimer quelques photos
c'est tout avant le premier oui alors ça
m'étonnerait j'ai plein de photos de son
ex mais dernière voire supprimer aucune
donc plus tu en as raison il ya l'un
d'entre vous qui va dégager
je vous l'avais dit ou pas #f1 ku c'est
quoi cette musique assez moi j'ai mis
une petite musique je me suis dit petite
ambiance bon débrouillez vous entre vous
les vieux moi ils utilisent tous le
temps risque pas de me supprimer vient
pour thil cinq minutes et scroll pendant
des heures tu pourras paris scroll des
vidéos d'ados de 14 ans qui font du
playback donc si tu supprimes ne serait
pas plus mal
what de la bouche du mec qui propose que
des vidéos je mange bleus pendant 24
heures j'essaye des produits which
comment mon mal encore
enfin il regarde pas que sarah et leurs
vidéos dans son historique c'est quoi
dégustation j attaque au son couple à
sont intéressants à youtube et plus t on
arrête les gamineries on reste calme ok
on va supprimer twitter ne fait pas ça
pas du tout nouveau jeu super utile pour
suivre l'actu nous tweetons c'est tout
tu sert juste à suivre des mecs qui se
croit drôle et à retweeter des concours
ça peut même pas de preuve qu'il ya des
gagnants à ces concours ou alors tu te
fait pigeonner georges frêche à un jour
on va peut-être cas d une ps4 et là tout
va bien fermer sa gueule et toi
instagram jeu prédire que à paroles
suivent dès que tu sers à rien donc à
chaque parent doit alors pas du tout ah
ouais c'est qu'ils emilie rattache costi
une comédienne citoyens de ses films
alors moi je suis d'accord avec twitter
on peut supprimer instagram je fais déjà
les photos ça fait doublon je fais les
stories d'ailleurs aussi un donc
pourquoi personne ne regarde des stores
et wet chez les stories ces boîtes au
monde le sait pardon snapshots et moi du
vrai stories hashtag idée et si on
supprimait horloge non non non ouais on
peut pas merde pas supprimer non le
sourire oui mais c'est comme message la
regarder le hac c'était deux bons mois
on peut pas supprimer alors qu'il sert à
rien depuis je suis là plutôt pop
whatsapp c'est aussi mon fils messenger
qui envoient des messages à nom prend
pas trop la grosse télé ni quoi papa non
mais t'inquiète pas messenger est arrivé
ouais je les messages sebha les vrais
messages des messages avec les pattes ya
des délires et où tu vois supprimer le
longuement germé khouya comment tu
parles de hashtag on se calme bon nous
on est en page une prime à craindre si
l'on supprime une application c'est
forcément une application en page 2
twitter a raison enfin je deviens genre
hubert damien il est fauché l'utilisent
jamais autant les supprimer je tiens à
rappeler que je suis quand même très
pratique lorsque damien rentrer
totalement bourré à 4 heures du matin
qui a pu le métro vous cherchez des
dépenses inutiles
tournez vous plutôt vers tinner quoi
voulez me supprimer bien sûr il a pris
l'abonnement tender premium les booth
lecomte god la totale e-match que dalle
abonnement gold
on sait quoi ça c'est quoi j'ai vu sa
passe est supprimée push loop le début
que ça coûte il a surtout du mal à
oublier son ex
exactement il rêve créer un compte
anonyme pour continuer à la suivre sur
instagram et il se morfond sur lui-même
sans sortir de chez lui
et là paf j'interdis avec des sushis ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta temps le restaurant
japonais juste en face de la partie il
peut se déplacer quand même des libéraux
tu sers à rien on supprime mais tu sais
pas ce que c'est que des primes et
google maps et regarde un burger satar
plaisir merci mais j'avais faim en plus
devant profiter de -20% sur le cassoulet
grade ou qu'est ce qu'on l'entende la
casse ou la grèce parce qu'il a pas pris
un abonnement payant voire des mois mais
des applications je sais pas ce que
c'est
qu'est ce que c'est la caf alors moisson
supprime on est à la rue clairement non
à la caf voit d'ailleurs petite
parenthèse mais on doit 5 euros à tome 1
les bons comptes font les bons amis
après caen reste beauté avec lui on
squatte son compte quand même et aller à
non mais pour l'argent vous inquiétez
pas damien iehl à trouver un business de
fou on revend ses vêtements d'occasion
sur vintage attend on gagne de l'argent
avec ça oui bah surtout les sous
vêtements bien vendu pas mal salle
puisque les vendeurs demander ça 1 le
coup dit qu'elles sont c'était bizarre
ce temps des dégâts mais c'est qui ce
mec en page de la work out c'est pour
qu'il fasse son sport de manière
quotidienne fait sur qui tu as déjà
ouverts parce que moi je vois ces photos
tous les jours peut dire qu'ils gagnent
de la grèce pas du muscle effectivement
il m'a jamais ouvert mais si me supprime
il peut dire adieu à son futur
creuserait fouet le corps de rêve moi je
veux bien ça m'aiderait à match est à
sec mais c'est ce qu'elle dit gars
qu'elle est belle bien moi ça élimine al
facebook
bello nadine km bouquet attendait
pourquoi ne supprimerait pas toi
facebook facebook ou non non non pas du
tout attendent et nous on est très
important avec mon fils messenger on
garde contact avec les gens avec les
tontons des tatas c'est tout et les
anniversaires
raisani les anniversaires qui c'est qui
les retient pour vous et ben c'est bibi
tu viens de dire c'est bibi
je m'attaque loges ouais surtout
contenir les anniversaires je peux le
faire ben non je supprime facebook on
s'en bat les couilles le mec il est vu
comme le monde à l'aise années yann
hashtag à dieu non maintenant je sais
faire les événements je suis pris un nom
mais pas s'il vous plaît pas la croix
à nouveau message c'est sa soeur qui dit
j'ai perdu les eaux je suis sage leur
jeu vers l'hôpital parce que tu peux
venir me chercher
musique dramatique
ok tout le monde on reste des terres
dame elle a besoin de nous et l'uci
vient de m'envoyer sa localisation
tiens ok je chope le chemin le plus
rapide pour la rejoindre
oh merde les lignes de métro qui en
travaux c'est pas grave on va les
trouver un vélo à proximité va faire du
sport c'est très bien pour lui et un
vélo et s'il part maintenant il peut
arriver au point de rendez-vous à 16h52
voire cinquante trois pour récupérer sa
sortie une fois arrivé je commande un
chauffeur et hop direction l'hôpital
coûte combien une course hubert s'en bat
les couilles comme ça ça coûte aller en
france
je contacte les cousins et cousines et
faire les soeurs facebook n'a qu'à
contacter les parents les grands-parents
les tontons des tatas ont fait ça
messenger sonne moi je vois un petit
story un point que je vais être tentons
hashtag famille hashtag fierté 0 laïque
faut attendre un peu
c'est long
merci d'avoir été là alors c'est normal
content pour toi rien oui mais où il est
rouge qui face à premières photos
absolument d'accord je voulais que cela
prenne comme ça vous êtes tous les trois
dessus oui oui du peuple est une petite
seconde
et ça recommence et c'est parti
vous inquiétez pas on va faire ce qu'ils
devaient faire depuis très longtemps
supprimer les photos de son ex pièces et
veut voir l' espace libre hashtag
soulagement aucun dépôt l'objectif de 6
merci a ajouté m non merci
vous aussi jeter n'importe quoi pendant
débuté mon frère quand louis tussaud
[Musique]